celebrity tv therapist laura berman has
revealed that her teenage son
died of a deadly drug overdose on sunday
she shared this emotional post on
instagram it says this my beautiful boy
is gone
16 years old sheltering at home a drug
dealer connected with him on snapchat
and gave him fentanyl laced xanax or
percocet
toxicology will tell and he overdosed in
his room
still trying to wrap my hand around that
berman is asking snapchat to work with
police on this
investigation and snapchat says it is
committed to working with law
enforcement in this case
and that it has zero tolerance for
anyone using its platform for illegal
purposes
snapchat also said it's constantly
improving technology to detect
drug-related activity
so that we can intervene proactively
laura berman and her husband samuel
chapman join us now to discuss
first lauren sam i just want to say i am
so sorry to hear about your son's death
i couldn't believe it when i heard the
news yesterday
and i can't imagine i really can't
imagine the pain that the two of you are
feeling this is still so raw and so
fresh
and i marvel that you're sitting here
with us today because many parents
myself included be in the fetal position
would be hard to sit upright
how and why did you decide you want to
share this story and i also think
nobody knows what they'll do until
they're in a position like this
laura again i'm so sorry thank you gail
um i would have assumed i was and i have
been
most of the time in a fetal position um
you know honestly i just out of complete
helplessness
and rage i i needed to do something
so i just posted on my social media and
you know the outpouring of love and
support and from platforms like this
has has really meant the world and at
first
you know i just said no and then as the
request kept coming
to get this story out you know i i
figured
sammy must have something to do with
this and if i can
use what happened to him to just save
one life
that helps at least if not with the
grief with the helplessness
yeah you said in your post laura we
watched him so closely
straight a student getting ready for
college experimentation gone bad he got
the drugs delivered to his house
sam did your son have a known drug
problem did you suspect that he was
using drugs at all well he
experimented like many teens with
marijuana but never a hard drug had
crossed the threshold of our home as far
as we knew
so this was a total shock and i don't
think that's the right word when
you walk in and you find your son dead
on the floor
i i wish it were me oh my gosh how did
you
know that he got the drugs from snapchat
i didn't even know that's possible
help me understand what exactly does
that mean
i didn't know this was possible either i
thought it was a place
you know where kids hang out with other
kids and maybe do a couple of
you know risque things with each other
because of the way the app is designed
to disappear as each post
is seen but um his friend was kind
enough
you know as i was trying to figure out
what happened his friend was kind enough
to share
a screenshot that our son had sent him
of a drug dealer that he had connected
with or had connected with him
on snapchat who um you know had created
a menu
and would and uh and had a twitter and a
snapchat handle to reach him
and would deliver it to your door so you
know on one of his little
quick walks around the neighborhood to
get some air between classes he must
have
you know met a dealer in his outside our
home
and brought it into the house that way
and we all think snapchat is the place
for kids to do
what they want to do because it's sweet
where other kids are but the reason the
kids are there is because of the
functionality that allows things to be
secret but a screen grab has whatever
you do on snapchat
tag you for the rest of your life and
it's turned into a place where kids
bully
and sext and drug dealers find them and
what that means is dangerous you said
you think it was fentanyl laced with
something was he in any kind of pain
that he'd be taking these drugs to begin
with
or do you think he knew what he was
taking no
he had no idea he was so he was so
careful
about his health he researched
everything always
he had so many dreams and so many plans
he
he was getting ready to apply to college
this year or the end of this year
he wanted to go to new york university
he wanted to travel the world
i mean he had so many plants and um
also knew the risks of
you know drugs and fentanyl and and and
we talked about it so much
and what i learned from the police is
there is a rash
of deaths around the country you know as
well as especially in los angeles
of you know kids doing this stupid
experimentation not realizing
that their drugs are being laced with
fentanyl because from the
uh from the dealer's perspective that
makes them more addicted so it's better
for business but it causes
you know overdose so easily and death
especially in kids whose bodies can't
handle it
yeah sam in laura's post she said we
were watching
closely you said you knew that he was he
was
taking marijuana or smoking marijuana
had you had any discussion with him
laura touched on it
briefly about you were worried about him
getting into trouble
because i think all these parents who
are sitting there watching you know your
kids are in the room
you think you know what your kids are
doing you think okay he's doing some
stuff that we don't approve of but we
don't think he's doing that and so i'm
trying to figure out what is the message
for parents today
did you have any suspicion whatsoever
that maybe he's getting into something
that's a lot more serious than he
realizes sam
we did not we were concerned because
of the marijuana so we would check on
him every hour and make sure things
weren't happening
but the real message to parents is it's
work to check on your kids social media
and most of us don't do it we don't even
know how to get onto their devices most
of us much less are we monitoring what
they're doing
and that's a life or death miss for us
yeah and
what have you had any conversations with
snapchat you we we read the statement
have you all reached out to them
directly what do you want them to do
the police are the ones who reach out
and when they reach out to snapchat
they do not get help uh snapchat has
pledged help
publicly and said nothing to us uh
they're just doing it in a
press release and we're concerned
that the santa monica police tell us
that both snapchat and twitter do not
help them when there's an investigation
all right the most they're willing to do
is bring down a profile and then
lauren sam we thank you so much i'm
sorry we have to go i really appreciate
you
i'm in awe really that you're here but i
think that you will help many people
today and again i'm so sorry
for the loss of your son thank you thank
you for taking the time